like you said earlier you've been locked
up previously but like
with what happened recently did that
kind of refocus you on what's important
like maybe like make your circle smaller
did that kind of change anything you're
doing as far as how you move or
maybe the things you talk about
not really like how would i talk because
i don't talk about crazy stuff but
yeah like circle wise not really though
because you know you always well me i'm
always analyzing seeing what i can make
better because you know people ain't
perfect so if you like
then once you be [ __ ] up you keep
[ __ ] up just start to sit back and
analyze then you gonna move a certain
way
yeah i mean when you when you get like
certain [ __ ] that you can't jeopardize
or like if you leave or something
what what's going to happen with this to
this person yeah so just think about
that [ __ ] are you on the other side of
your situation or is it still open
on the other side like it's always of
the legal [ __ ] yeah every yeah obviously
i don't really want to speak too much on
this like that topic though yeah that's
fair and when you feel comfortable with
me trying to 100 man it's just crazy
because like you know it feels like now
rappers are targets like you can't even
that's the most dangerous job in the
world yeah i feel like
you got to go to clubs you got to
like you dropping your location off from
the beach
[Music]
and then you know people
they just think rappers be and they
they think i don't know i feel like
people just feel like rappers like
you know they don't deserve all that
sometimes well that is true right if you
if you really think about it if you have
enemies you openly advertise where
you're gonna be often yeah
like right and then on the other end
for whatever reason
legally all kinds of [ __ ] like
artists like music gets combed through
and i feel like artists are an easy
target for
any sort of like agency who wants to
just pick on somebody you know what i'm
saying and yeah on both sides of the
coin i just feel like it's like it's
like a tough position to be in at times
and people don't even realize
yeah that's most definitely the most
dangerous thing though do you ever feel
stressed out like like [ __ ] man i'm
stressed or you know what's because i'm
a rapper yeah man i mean [ __ ] you
obviously got some like pretty public
beefs that have what happened and i
don't know not not he's not even about
that though i don't think i'll be
stressed because like
a lot of fake stuff be going on
like just just fake stuff like just
because who you is people certain people
might hit you up then you might feel
like it's real love but then end up not
it's like um